as the sun went down the cues filed on
many thousands willing to wait wanting
to capture this moment in history
it was a somber march through part of
the capital where the usual funds stood
still
cues at times stretched three miles
people waited for hours
but for so many this made it all worth
it in the ancient westminster hall a
final chance for reflection for respect
and for the lucky like genie who met the
queen remembering too
she has his intense enthusiasm
and then she looked up and she saw him
in a beautiful smile
amazing skin
wonderful eyes
that tiny ground on top of the coffin
and it just made your heart turn over
oh a truly great lady
i've come from quite a military family
so the queen has always been quite part
of our family and i just felt that i
needed to she always been in our life
she's like an extra grandmother to us
really
and we've lost that
amongst those who waited were many who
served who called the queen their boss
john left his home in dorset at 2 30 am
yesterday so determined to say thank you
went past the casket and obviously as a
serviceman saluted
and i wanted to make sure i did it right
because she
was a stickler on parades for making
sure
everything was right a lot of people see
her as a
as a person rather than the queen and
that's what she was to me as well
there is a real poignancy to the fact
that even now in the dead of night
people just keep coming and this cue
snakes for miles and is expected to grow
in the coming days everyone's here to in
their own way share something that's
very public and historic but also
personal and intimate too
[Music]
it was yesterday when the queen made her
final departure from the place she
called the office
flanked by those who served her followed
by her four children along with princess
william and harry
the grief of her people public
applause breaking out for their queen
party
slow
march
and finally she was transported inside
from the gun carriage that bore her her
extended family watching on as her lying
in state began
after what must have been a wearying few
days the king returned to his home in
highgrove he will rest and reflect today
but no such rest for some in the very
early hours rehearsals for the funeral
which will take place
[Music]
an empty coffin for now and a sense of
how moving it will be
but before that tens of thousands will
pass through here a nation's turn to say
thank you helen smith sky news
westminster